so i just you know sitting here in the
kitchen
thinking as i do that's how i do it i
talked to a lot of brands this morning
and there was a common theme and i felt
inspired to make a video you know a lot
of people are starting to understand
the real line in the sand between what
facebook can do and what twitter can do
and what other social networks and
platforms can do
and really facebook is so robust and
with customizable fan pages
kyle with the customizable fan pages
you know there's so much more
flexibility to storytell but what's very
powerful about twitter and other
platforms and even leaving comments on
your blog
i think that brands have completely lost
touch
or more importantly people have
underestimated
the value of a thank you and you're
welcome
showing people comments on let's say
twitter where people say um i just tried
this product and it was delicious
and then watching these brand people
look at me and say well what do you do
with that
you say thank you or you say
you're welcome when somebody says our
service was unbelievable by ups
well ups get in there and say you're
welcome and thank you for using us the
power of thank you when you're welcome
is so much higher than people recognize
and the ability to say it
is easier than ever so start saying